so I've prepared some slide sort of off
the cuff for the webinar today and it's
all about data wrangling and one thing
I'll point out after I introduce myself
I'm Garrett growler mins and I work for
our studio and I write books on our and
teach people how to program with our and
all the slides I'm going to show you
today are available online they're
available right now so you could
download them or later you're at this
link at the bottom of the slide but I
put that link in the slide template so
it'll show up on any slide you don't
have to reach there right now to get it
if you want to follow me on Twitter
there's my twitter address and also my
email address if you have any questions
you'd like to follow up with this
webinar we'll we'll go through two
packages that have the Wickham my
colleague made and they're both really
geared towards working with the
structure of data so that's the tidy our
package and the deep liar package and
then what I'm going over today really
follows closely a cheat sheet that we
published a couple of days ago so this
is a cheat sheet you could download at
the link at the bottom of the slide here
and it's a two-page sheet that just
summarizes the tidier package in the
deep hire package so it's a great
resource for remembering the functions
that would go go through today and also
for this remembering functions in
general as you work with data so before
we really get into data wrangling
there's a couple of ground rules that I
want to familiarize you with so these
two packages introduced some things into
our that makes our work better but also
makes our look a little different so I
just wanna make sure you're comfortable
with that before we start using them and
the first is the table structure or
table TBL and what is what a table is
I'm gonna say table looks like don't
like Ted will but it's just a data frame
basically you can think of as a data
frame that appears two differently in
your console window so for example if I
go over here to my our window this is
just our studio window that I on the
side here I and I open up a familiar
library like ggplot2 you there is a data
set in here called diamonds which is
humongous and if you try to look at this
data frame well this will happen it it
fills up my screen and it
some point R tells me that it's not
going to show the rest of the data this
data set is 52 thousand rows and really
what I do see here isn't very helpful a
fills up my memory buffer which means I
can't see what I did before and B I
can't even see the names of this data
frame so what a table is is a new class
that you could give to a data structure
like diamonds sorry and it's implemented
through the deep-fryer package here so I
can change diamonds into a table with
this function table underscore D F and
now I have the same data frame here but
the print method is only going to show
me the part of the data frame that fits
in my console window so it showed me
right now that there's a variable called
Y and a variable called Z in the diamond
stated frame that went off the side of
the window instead of wrapping them
below our now let's just go tell me
these variables are here but they're not
shown and then instead of showing me
52,000 rows it's just going to show me
ten rows so this is a more pretty way to
look at your data if I were to change my
console window to something wider and
then I looked at my table of diamonds
I get those extra variables here it pays
attention to how wide my window is so it
knows how many variables that can show I
called this again not only shows up the
depth and so on
so this is a very useful way to look at
large data sets or work with large data
sets but you at times will still want to
see your complete data so there's a
function I recommend to use when you
want to look at the entire dataset and
that's the view function it's in base R
and if you call it from our studio
we'll open up a spreadsheet like view
window where you could check out your
data set almost as if it were an Excel
document keep in mind that's view with
the capital V and you could use this on
any data frame that you have an R now
there's one last function that really
changes how our looks and that's the
pipe operator this comes from the my
greeter package but it's imported by the
deep liar package and it's a different
way to write the same code that you'd
write before so you can probably
recognize what this command would do
here we haven't looked at select we'll
look at that today but it's calling
select on an object called tbh and then
it has some arguments here the pipe
operator allows you to pipe in the first
argument of select so I'd write TB pipe
select child to elderly and what the
upper will do is they'll insert TB as
the first argument of select so these
two lines of code would do the same
thing if we come over here we could you
know ain't take a look at that so if I
had diamonds I could pipe in I just take
one variable from diamonds maybe the X
column and I could pipe that into the
mean and if I run this code let's go
give me the mean of the X column which
is the same as if I did mean diamond sex
so at this point it might not be obvious
why you'd use pipe over anything else
but the cool thing about this format is
you can start chaining arguments
together so if I wander around every
value in the X column of diamonds to the
second decimal place and then take the
mean I can use this code here which
won't look all that different instead of
actually saying like okay let's around
all the stuff and save that and then
call mean on the output as your chains
get longer and longer this becomes much
more efficient than actually managing
where you save the in between states
so let's take a look at the functions I
can actually help you wrangle data and
what I mean by data wrangling is what
other people call munging or transform
your data or manipulating it and the
reason I use the word wrangling is it
sort of captures how painful this
process can be so there's an article we
link to in the registration email from
The New York Times that said that about
you know 50 to 80 percent of the data
scientists time was spent doing things
like munching and wrangling their data
it also offered a new word for data
wrangling which was data janitor work
which I found amusing
so I don't know where they got this
statistic from but I think a lot of
people would say that's just getting the
format of your data into a format that
you can work with is time consuming and
it's often boring and painful and if you
could do that more efficiently that
would be a big win and the functions
we'll look at today will help you do
that
normally when you angle your data you
have two goals first you might need to
make your data set suitable to a
particular piece of software for example
we're going to need to make our data a
suitable tocar because that's what we're
using
and then second you can actually reveal
information by changing the format and
the structure of your data let's start
with this first goal making our data
suitable for our so your data sets can
come in many different formats but
there's one that are definitely prefers
more than the others and I have some toy
data sets in this package which I've
built on github you can download it if
you want to use these data sets it's
completely not necessary I'll be using
these and you could just sit back and
watch but should you want to install
this package first install the dev tools
package which is on crayon and then use
the installed github command in dev
tools to install this from the link our
studio - Edie aw are inside this data
frame my inside this package I have some
data frames that are all fairly small
but demonstrate the sort of layout and
formatting issues that you might
encounter it with data in our for
example here are three data frames from
the package one some data about
hurricanes in the Atlantic Ocean one
some cases of a disease in this case TB
in different countries in different
years now
some data about pollution and we can go
through these three data frames and try
to analyze what they contain
in particular we could look at what
variables are in each of the data frames
so when the storms data frame is pretty
straightforward we have a variable that
talks about the names of each of our
storms a variable has something do with
the wind it's actually the maximum wind
speed recorded for each storm a variable
that records the pressure of each storm
and the date on which these measurements
are made so there's four variables in
that data frame if we turn our attention
to the cases data frame we'll see that
we have a variable that has some sort of
country code so we see France which land
in the United States there we have a
variable that lists different years 2011
2012 2013 and we have a variable that's
left over that's something like a
frequency or a count or you might just
call it n that's here and if you compare
cases the storms you can see already
that we have a difference between the
two data frames they store the values of
their variables in different ways and
storms each variable is put in so in
column in cases one variables in a field
of cells once across the column headers
and ones in its own column when we get
to pollution we see any different
formats still we have a variable that's
different city names and then it looks
like we have a variable that describes
particle size and variable that
describes some sort of amount but I
think you can also argue and this is
what I would argue that we actually have
a variable which is the amount of large
particles that each of these cities has
and its air and the second variable
which is the amount of small particles
that each city has in its air and if you
wanted to compute some number for each
city like the ratio of large to small
particles then you'd have to treat these
things as separate variables to do math
with them so we can look at this data
frame as having three variables that are
structured in a different way so this is
what I mean by data sets come in many
different formats but if you look
how you'd pull the values of these
different variables out of these data
frames you'll see that one of these
formats is much nicer with our code than
others in the storms data frame you pull
out each variable using the same syntax
the name of the data frame dollar sign
the name of the column that you want but
if you want to pull out the value so say
da the count variable from cases you'd
actually have to extract a bunch of
cells and paste them together in some
way or the names of the columns will
pull them together when you move to
pollution you have to do something
similar and this is bad because when you
write your code you want to be able to
make it as generalizable and as
automated as possible and if you have to
stop and look at the data set that
you're working with and then think about
how to extract the values of the
variable you want within that data set
well then this going to be really hard
to write a piece of code that will work
with other data sets as well and the
chance for making an error would be much
greater
so just due to the way our works its
syntax structure and everything it's
much easier to work with your data if
each variables in its own call but
there's other advantages as well if we
look at the storms data frame and
consider making some sort of new
variable in this case the ratio of
pressure to wind meteor logically I
don't think that's a meaningful variable
but this is similar to things you do
with your own data you'd use some math
like this and our and what that code
would do is it first extract the
pressure variable storms and then it
would extract the wind variable and it
divided the two and the way our operates
is is it's go to element wise operations
so instead of doing some sort of linear
algebra thing here can just go pair up
the first value of each vector the
second value third that and so on and
within those those elements I'll do the
task of division and so we get a vector
that has at the end just as many values
as the original vectors now this is
great if you put your data in such a way
that each variables in its own column
and then each row contains a single
observation because what element wise
operations would do is it'll make sure
that the values of one observation are
only paired with other values from the
same observation which is add a
scientist is just what you want we
wouldn't want to divide the pressure of
Alberto by the wind speed of Alec
that's really not a meaning for the
quantity so we want to make sure we keep
the pressure of Alberta with the wind of
Alberta and the pressure of Alex with
the wind of Alex and so on well the
structure of the storms data frame makes
that happen automatically it's taking
advantage of ours
Elmen wise operations so that's what we
round about way to say that there's one
structure that just works well with the
natural quirks of our and if you put
your data into that structure before you
begin to analyze your data you'll have a
much quicker more efficient experience
when you work with that data in and I'm
going all that data structure tidy data
this is a term and Benes by or
popularized by Hadley the author of Tidy
R&D pyre and what it amounts to is you
take your data you make sure that each
variable is saved in its own column
which we saw storms did make sure each
observation is saved in its own row not
going to go into what an observation is
here but it
obvious and puzzling at the same time
and then finally you want to put
basically all the data that you plan to
work with in the same data table before
you start working with it otherwise
we'll be recombining your data every
time you make some sort of adjustment to
it so if you make your data tidy with
variables and columns observations and
rows and the type of data in its own
table it'll be easy to access your
variables and you'll automatically
preserve observations as you do things
to your data so that's sort of the goal
tie gr is the means to get there
it's a package that picks up where
reshape to left off if you are a user of
reshape or reshape to and tidier has two
main functions gathering spread lets do
similar things as cast and melt if
you're coming from the reshape world and
then there's several other functions
will look at in there but these are the
main ones and let's take a peek at them
so this is the cases data frame this is
how the variables were distributed what
I'd like you to do and just for 30
seconds because I can't really check in
with you guys are communicated with you
imagine how the state frame would look
like if you restructured it to be
similar to storms if it was tidy and had
the variables country year and n I think
if you try to scribble this out on a
sheet of paper or something it'd make it
much easier to follow what gather does
which we'll look at in a second
all right so hopefully you had a chance
to
what this data would look like in a
different format and this is what I
proposed this day so I would look like
in a tidy format I want to keep all of
the information in the data set and we
want to keep the variables are there and
the values are there we just want to
restructure them so the variables each
appear in their own column and we know
that the columns we want to end up with
are something like country year and the
N and we can also look at the old dates
at that turn what values need to go in
which rows of the new data set we need
to have some combination of France the
year 2011 and live this end value for
that combination needs to be 7000 we
also need a combination of you know
Germany in 2011 with its own value and
basically we need to port over all the
values in this field of cells into our
new data frame but when we're done our
data frame will look like this so this
is a tidy version version of the cases
data frame now it's very easy to pull
out each of these variables by selecting
the column name and we can do this sort
of thing with the gather function and
before we do it want to develop one
piece of vocabulary so if you look at
the output you see it basically took the
right-hand side of this data frame and
turn it into two columns the first
column is a key column these are the
names that these cells had in the the
previous data frame the column names and
we'll call the second column of value
column so these are actual values that
appeared in that field of cells maybe
the key value pair is actually pretty
common so we're going to use gather to
take a cells and turn it into just two
columns a key column and a value call
this is how the function works this
function comes with the tidy our library
and you first get at the name with the
data frame that you want to clean up and
then you give it the name that you want
to use for the key column that results
in the name that you'll use for the
value column so we happen to be moving
column names that were years into its
own key column and cell values that were
you know n for frequency into their own
column column but you know gather and
tidier can't know what
those things actually stand for so here
we get to tell them what's the name then
you call us then finally we just tell
gathered which of the columns we wanted
to use when it builds those final two
columns you may remember in the case of
the stator frame the first column is
already tidy the countries were already
in their own column so we don't include
one in this index here we leave 1b we
just included two through four those
were the columns that were not tidy when
you do this your data will go from here
to there so at this point if you
downloaded the I don't it's called a
dollar package you could load it and
you'll see that you know the storms data
sets in there the cases data sets in
there actually all the data sets on my
cheat sheet are in there and all the day
sets we'll go over today and so if I
took the code here I can run in our and
verify that gather comes from tidy edit
ID our library all right now you can see
that we're going from our rectangular
data frame our table to our tidy data
frame here so I'm I know there'll be a
lot of functions go through but I'm just
gonna keep pushing forward because you
know 45 minutes isn't that long time
okay so this is our pollutions data set
and it has three variables distribute
like this we can make this data set tidy
with a column called City of Concord
large from Colin called small before we
do try to picture in your mind what that
would look like which will help you
understand the goal we're working
towards in the next few slides
so the cases dataframe looked like
rectangular data that's the sort of data
that you'll find very often and you only
have a few variables and you want
display and and a format that fits in a
paper pretty well I don't know what to
call this sort of data but it exists
quite often as well and if you can
switch this sort data and rectangular
data you pretty much have full control
over and format your data right so
here's the pollution de set as it is and
we want to make it a data frame that has
these columns in it and just like before
it's only a matter of retraining the
combinations that appear in the original
data frame in our new data frame and
when we do that this is what the result
looks like see it's tidy it's more
rectangular than the previous data frame
now there's fewer rows we've removed
some redundancy here basically we've
made something that looks more like the
cases data frame from before when we did
this operation we again we're working
you could think of it as working with
the key column and a value column the
operation that we're going to the
function that does this operation is
called spread and what it does is it
looks at the original data set and you
give it a column to use as a key column
and a column uses a value column and
I'll use those columns to recreate a
field of cells but the way you call
spread is the idea would be that the
field of cells to recreate will be a
tidy field of cells
the syntax for spread is you give it the
data frame you want to reshape you give
it the name of the column use as a key
column in the original data and the name
of the column uses the value column in
the original data here that size and
amount and then it makes a transition
for you
you can think of
bread is taking data that's in a
key-value column format and putting into
a field of cells format or rectangular
table format whatever vocabulary you
like you can think of gatherers doing
the opposite and by going back and forth
between gather and spread you could
actually move values into call names out
of column names variables since you like
rectangular format a tidy format and
since you don't have to apply spread or
apply gather to the same columns each
time just by iterating between these two
functions you can take the same data
preserve all the combinations in the
data and make the layout very very
different than it was to begin line so
the tiger package also has two other
functions I think are useful but not
always going to be that useful if you
looked at the storms data set and you're
very persnickety you might notice that
actually has three more variables in
there you could extract a year variable
from the day a month variable in the day
variable
and those variables are all combined
into one column here the date column
what separate does is it takes a single
column and it splits it up into multiple
columns based on some sort of separating
character so this is really easy with
dates because dates normally have some
sort separator between the Year month
and a and if we ran this code above here
we get a new data frame where the day
column has been split into a year on the
day three columns if I save that as
storms two then I could use unite which
does the inverse it takes several
columns and puts them together in the
same column adding a separator between
the values of the previous columns so
that's a great way to recreate some
dates although in this case those dates
would be character strings you need to
reparse them if you want them to behave
as dates in our that's another story
so just to recap
about the tiger package is my primarily
works with the layout of your data it
reshapes the layout use the gather
function in the spread function to
change the shapes back and forth they're
complementary and then you can use
separate and unite to split up in unite
columns they're also complementary this
this package is designed basically to
get data into that tidy format which is
the most efficient way to work with it
in our but let's turn our attention now
to the deep higher package which has a
different design data sets contain more
information than they display and deep
liar's designed to help you sort of
access that information so you'll need
to run my brady plier before you use the
functions in this package you'll also
need to install the package of course if
you want to use it the main functions
that we'll use for manipulating data are
listed here there help pages but we'll
just go through them one at a time
also I don't think I'll have a chance to
open up this data set by with planning
may be using this for some examples the
NYC flights 13 package just contains
datasets related to flights that went in
and out of New York City it has a great
place to look at things as real data and
it's somewhat interesting especially if
you fly into New York City so when it
comes to the accessing information in
your data frame it can help to just
extract information that's already there
to avoid the sort of overwhelming amount
of distraction that the other variables
provides so you can extract variables
you can extract observations you could
drive new variables and you can change
the unit of analysis that the datasets
place and I'll talk about that let me
get there deep liar provides four
functions each dedicated to doing one of
these things and let's take a look at
them starting with select so select is
very simple it's a way for you to just
pull out variables or columns from a
data frame so if I only wanted the storm
column in the pressure column from the
storms data frame then I could select
from storms the storm and pressure
column and you could list as many column
names or as few column names as you want
there and it will bring back everything
you list so that's easy enough to do in
our and why you might ask why would you
select to do it
well one thing that's like does is it
provides more ways to specify which
columns you want so you'll know that if
you use brackets and integer sub setting
you could put a negative sign in front
of an integer and that stands in our
forgive me everything except this
integer both select you could put a
negative sign in front of a name and
you'll get back everything except that
name so here we did everything except
the storm call you could also use the
colon notation to get a range of
variables so this would say give him
back the wind variable the date variable
and any variable that appears in between
them so would I do the same as a
previous command and then there's other
functions that you can use inside of
select come with deep wire that make it
even easier so here's a list of those
functions and you can see they allow you
to pull out columns whose names have
like a certain string in them or a
certain rate of expression or begin with
a certain word or end with a certain
word or you know is that a group of
names and so on so if you have a very
large data set selecting variables out
of it might be an important task these
functions might make it very easy for
you to sort of search through the
variable name space in an automated
fashion filter is analogous says select
except instead of selecting columns it
brings back rows or if your day is tiny
these would be observations and the way
filter works is you give it a logical
test so here I'm giving it the test
where wind is greater than or equal to
50 what filter will do is will apply
that test to each row in your data frame
and give you back just the roads that
pass the test you can combine tests by
putting a comma in between tests and
what filter will do is they'll combine
them as if there is an end statement
between them so these are only the rows
where the wind is greater than 50 and
the name the storm name is in Alberta
Alex and Alison if you want to do an or
condition we just use the boolean
operator for or and are to combine two
tests into a single test that's the the
pipe operator so filter we're
best if you know how to use logical
tests in our and here's a quick list of
the logical tests that exists in our the
table on the right are boolean operators
these combine to a more logical test
into a single logical test so you'll get
single true or false and the ones on the
left actually do logical operations
you'll notice at the bottom that is an a
an exclamation mark is that na are in
there which means filters a great way to
window out rows that have na values if
you combine it with this dot na or
exclamation mark is na all right
the mutate function takes your data
frame and it returns a copy of the data
frame with new variables added to it
normally these will be variables that
you derive from the variables that exist
in your data so before we had sort of
the bogus example of calculating a ratio
variable from the wind and pressure
variable storms the information that
ratio variable was only data to begin
with it just wasn't on display but you
you can logically drive it from the data
that's there and this is how you do it
with mutate I you run your take on the
data frame we want to add to or change
and then you give it the name of the new
column you want to make and you set that
equal to some expression that will make
the values so the new column you can
make more than one column at the same
time and you can even use a column to
make a new column in the same command
make sure that the first column appears
before the columns that rely on it so
here in reverse relies on ratio and
since ratio appears first inverse will
be able to find ratio and use it to
calculate numbers this can
mutate doesn't actually affect your
original data frame it returns a data
frame that has the new variables added
to it so if you want to save that data
frame use those variables later you'll
need to assign it to an object there are
a lot of functions that are useful to
use with mutate to making variables this
is a short list of them this list by the
way also appears on that cheat sheet
goals you can download from the our
studio website and each of these
functions has something in common they
all take a vector and return vector the
same length so if you want to add a
column on to your data frame that
columns gonna have to have values for
each row in the data frame when you use
these functions you'll get a set of
values that will fit right up with your
data frame you can call these window
functions because they sort of pass the
whole vector through a window and the
vector changes but each element is still
represented at the end okay so the last
of those four functions we we listed
with summarize in summarize takes a data
frame and a calculate summary statistics
from it you get back a new data frame
and usually that new data frame is much
much smaller for example here I'm
summarizing the pollution data frame by
calculating the median value of the
mouse I only need one value to show the
median so my new data frame only has one
row I'm also calculating the variance so
my flu works similar to mutate you give
it the name of the new columns you want
in your new summary data frame and then
you set those names equal to the the R
code that will build those values like
mutate
functions that seem to work best with
summarize and things like the standard
statistical estimators men means
variants standard deviation median and
all these functions are similar to each
other in a corner way
unlike the window function C's with
mutate these functions actually all take
a vector or group of numbers and return
a single number so you could think them
as summarizing functions or summary
functions and when you use some
summarize you'll want to use these
summarizing functions to build your
summary statistics there's one more
function in deep liar that doesn't
really add to your data or subtract from
it but you can consider like a fifth
Horseman of the player and that's a
range what a range will do is they'll
rearrange the order of the rows in your
data frame based on the value of one of
the columns so here I rearrange the rows
and storms based on the value of wind
and if we color-coded this data set you
could see that it's easier to see that
whereas before the rows were not ordered
by wind value now they go from the row
with the smallest one value to the row
with the highest wind value if you want
to reorder them in a different way in
descending order you use this helper
function D ESC it stands for descend
just wrap that around the variable whose
values you want to be ordered from
highest to lowest so now the highest
wind is at the top of the dataframe
if you give a range one variable it will
range based on that variable and Tyus
will just occur in the order they appear
in the data frame but if you give it a
second or third variable arrange will
use that variables tie a tiebreaker
variable within rows that have the same
values of preceding variables so you can
see here that by adding D as a
tiebreaker the order of Aleks and Arthur
changes even though Alyx and Arthur both
had a wind speed of 45 the date of our
third comes before date of Alex
okay so I mentioned that pipe operator
earlier and this is where it really
starts to come into play you could
select data from your data frame you
know in the regular are away well you
can do the same thing with the pipe
operator so now I'm just piping storms
into the Select command same with filter
same with all these functions each of
these functions takes the name of the
data frame that's our first argument
which makes this really convenient and
then if you use the piping syntax it's
very simple to pipe the results after
one expression into a second expression
so if you want to first filter the rows
to extract all the rows for windscreen
50 and then take those results and
select two variables from it you could
just add a second pipe operator in the
selectmen at the end of your code if you
then want to mutate that data frame or
summarize it well then you could add a
third pipe operator in the next line and
so on and so on so it becomes very easy
to build off this sort of record of what
you're doing to transform your data and
it's very easy to add to that record and
then if you read through what we're
doing here I think this way of reading
code is actually very transparent take
storms then filter it to just a rows for
wind speeds gram 50 then select from it
storm and pressure just read the piping
operator is thin and I think it makes
your code very legible okay so you
should be able to guess with something
like this would you
you start with storms then you mutate it
to create a ratio variable and then you
select from adjust the storm variable on
the ratio variable what would your
output look like something like this if
you don't
typing percent greater than percent
there's a keyboard shortcut for that
operator it's command shift M on Mac and
ctrl shift m' on Windows but let's turn
our attention to unit of analysis I
apologize I realize I'm not answering
people's questions and actually when I'm
playing the slideshow I can't see your
questions but I will get to some of
yours at the end so this is where I
think those five functions I mentioned
are they're really become interesting
this is our pollution data set you know
it describes pollution particle amounts
in three different cities and we could
calculate the mean amount to some of the
amounts and the number of rows and the
state of frame and put them in the
summary data set if we look at that it's
summary de set on the side there well
alright let's look at pollution first
you'll notice it's a tidy de said it has
variables
it has observations and if you look at
the summary de set it also has variables
in this case three variables and it does
have an observation on just one
observation but each of these things
that mean the summoning in each of those
values describes the same thing and that
should raise the question what is it
that those values describe and if you
think of a mean of 42 or a sum of 252 or
even an N of six rows becomes pretty
clear that what they're describing is
this entire data set it's almost like
we've made measurements on de set we've
made an observation on the data set an
all-day set is is a grouping of
observations or grouping arose so if we
make observations on entire data set
well then we could also make
observations on subsets of a data set we
can make an observation on six rows why
not make an observation on two rows or
three observations on two rows and if we
did that then we could have mean sums
and ends that are keyed into in this
case different cities you know the mean
amount for New York the mean amount for
London mean malphur Beijing you can do
this sort of thing the screw price
operation by combining the group by
auction which comes from deep prior with
the summarized function that comes from
deep liar here's how it works if you run
group I on the data frame and then you
give group by the name of a column art
variable it will add some metadata to
the data frame that tells our or tells
deep wire with the different groups of
rows are in the data frame in this case
little group the data into three groups
one group for each unique value of the
city variable now at this point it
doesn't do anything if you just ran this
that metadata will stick around with
your data frame and the applier might
use it if you run a deep layer command
on that group data frame but in essence
you know it just shows up it's basically
here when you look at the table format
it'll tell you if the data is grouped
and what's grouped by in this case is
grouped by the city variable the magic
happens when you combine a group data
frame with summarize or mutate or filter
or not what deployer will do is apply
summarize in a group by fashion or
mutate and group by fashion and so on
where it makes sense so here if I first
group by city and then summarize to
calculate a mean summon end variable D
Pires going to split the data in groups
and conceptually it's going to apply the
summary each of the groups separately
and put those summaries back together
into a final data frame this will be my
result this is how you get group group
statistics or group wise summaries from
your data you'll notice that the three
variables like calculate with summarize
mean summon n or in the final data set
but to those d player has added the city
variable and that variable came from the
grouping criteria and it's necessary for
D player to add each variable that's
involved in the grouping process so we
know what the values that mean summon n
refer to so if we put this process
together this is what it looks like we
take our data we group it and we get
grouped by summaries in this case I'm
all I taken to mean the the row of the
summary that applies a small it's just
the mean of the small group in this data
set here I'm grouping by size before I
scoping by city the rows don't have to
be near each other in a group everything
will just be grouped together based on
common values wherever those values
appear in the dataset once you have
grouped
you can remove the grouping information
with the ungroup that can be reassuring
because you know sometimes I want
metadata just floating around but also
if you were to summarize a group data
set there will be some ungrouping that
occurs as well so this dataset doesn't
actually exist there is a TV data set in
the EDA WR package but it's much more
complicating this one this is a
simplified version but you can imagine
we could take this data set that as
different countries different years
different genders number of cases the TB
although there's more than one case 99
in Afghanistan anyways we could group it
in this case we could add more than one
variable to the grouping criteria and
what group I will do so I'll create a
separate group for each combination of
those variables so for example
Afghanistan in 1999 will be one group
Afghanistan in 2000 will be a separate
group and so on and then we can run
summarize on that and what we'll get is
you know our summary but when you run
summarize on groups correct data
summarize will strip off one variable
from the grouping criteria so now that
it's made this summary is go strip off
the leftmost variable know the rightmost
variable in this case that's a year and
what you'll end up with is a date is a
data set still grouped but it's only
grouped by country it's no longer
grouped by country and year now why do
that well this this output here on the
right was still grouped by country and
year each row would be a separate group
and at that point the grouping criteria
is not really that helpful go by
stripping off just the last grouping
criteria this will be grouped by country
and we can immediately run some rice on
it again and this time get summary
statistics based on the different
countries and now let's go peel off that
variable country and the data is no
longer grouped after we've summarized a
few times and this only applies to the
output that we get from this command
that's no longer grouped none of what
we're doing is going to affect the
actual TB dataset that's just going to
exist as it always has in memory so this
process
of grouping by many variables and then
summarizing peeling off one level of
grouping criterias Yugo is a way to
change the unit of analysis that your
data looks at for example we use the
process to make these four data sets
here they all come from the original TV
data but one of them is really
describing combinations of in this case
on the left country by year by sex and
then we change that to just country by
year and then we change that to just
country then we change that to the
entire dataset and different types
information can become apparent at
different levels of grouping here and
summarization so I know it's been a lot
this is definitely gonna be a whirlwind
tour but we're near the end you can
extract variables and observations with
selecting filter you can rearrange your
data with a range you can make new
variables with mutate and you can make
new observations on new units analysis
by combining goodbye with summarize so
there's one last thing that you will
probably want to do as you wrangle your
data with these packages and that's
combine multiple datasets into the same
data set there's a simple way to combine
data sets together in our if your data
sets were meant to go together you can
add them together by pacing one as extra
columns onto the first with the buying
calls command from deep liar there's
also a seed bind command and base are
buying calls is just a little more
optimized so that's why I'm showing you
bind calls this is somewhat dangerous to
do or has no way of checking whether the
rows are in the same order between the
data sets or whether when you combine
the day sets together the row describes
an observation then observation that
makes sense for example here you
probably want B to be on the second line
it's in the first line so use column
binding with caution make sure the data
is arranged for you to do you want to do
you could add the second data set as
additional rows to the bottom of your
first data set with bind rows or our
bind and base are again you need to make
sure that the variables are in the same
order and mean the same thing but it's
probably less risky than column binding
and then if you actually have two data
sets like this where they describe the
same variables those have different
observations that's very
you could actually use set operations on
these data sets so data frame set
operations come with deep liar you take
two data frames and get the union of
rows that appear in both data frames the
intersection of rows appear in both data
frames and the set difference arose that
promote data frames
that's just your basic Union
intersection set different things apply
it to data frames now normally when you
want to put data sets together you need
do something a little more involved and
that's what I call joining data' so
here's a trivial example here's two data
frames they both talk about the Beatles
ones a list of songs and who wrote each
of the songs then one's a list of the
artists in the Buell's and what each one
played or one of the instruments they
played and if you wanted to put these
things together into the same data set
so you match up the instrument that each
Beatle played with you know what song
they wrote you can do that with the left
join what left joy does is it takes the
names of two data frames and that takes
some joining criteria these would be the
name or names of columns that both
datasets share and then what it will do
is it'll go through the second data
frame find the pieces of information
that apply to rows in the first data
frame and add them where they belong in
that data frame so order is not
preserved the second date of frames
order is not preserved first day frame
yes that is preserved but things are
moved around to supply a play column
that actually makes sense with your data
frame and at the end you have rows and
your your output that's described a
unified observation John both row across
universe and played guitar guitar had
appear twice it's because John is also
in the second row and so it appears
twice there's no information about this
last row Buddy Holly who made Peggy Sue
so for the place column that gets an na
hey there's nothing we could put their
left joins aren't the only way to join
data together in an intelligent fashion
you do write join well this would be the
tax for if you want to join based on to
two columns both first and last I use
the C to make a vector of column names
and passed that to buy that's Lovejoy
left joint isn't the only way to join
datasets together you could do an inner
join which is a little more exclusive so
an inner join still puts the day sets
together in the same fashion but if
there's any row from the first dataframe
that doesn't have information the second
data frame like Peggy Sue and Buddy
Holly didn't appear in the second day
frame inner join will exclude that from
the results it just contains the row
side peered into both data frames then
let me come back to this no oh yeah I'm
sorry so we just released two new joins
on the slides you'll find them on the
cheat sheet those are right join in
outer join so right join is like a left
join but it's it's has the same effect
as if you switch the order of the day
frames appears artist person song second
that would give you the equivalent of a
right join the second data frames
prioritize over the first an outer join
is the complement of an inner join an
inner join only keeps the rows I appear
in both data frames and outer join keeps
every row that appears in any data frame
and you get a very big day frame at the
end but that pie has a bunch of missing
values you could look those up on the
chi chi then we have two filtering
joints ma join an anti join these don't
actually joined a sets together at all
these take the first day set and remove
rows from it based on what appears in
the second day set so what's MI join
will do is I'll take the first dataset
look at the data and see which rows have
an equivalent in the second data set and
return just those rows that have an
equivalent doesn't add anything to the
rows it just shows you what rows will
actually be joined should you do a join
in and hand side does the opposite it
shows you which rows do not have a claim
the second day set so you can use anti
join to see which rows will not be
joined when you do try so am i join an
anti join are good ways to sort of debug
or get a feel for how the joins going to
work ahead of time
so let's skip over some of this recap
again near the top of the hour so I just
want to point your attention to where
you can learn more this cheat sheet is a
really great and concise way to go about
learning how to wrangle data with these
two packages you could download it here
at this link we also have other cheat
sheets about other things there if you
want to practice with deep liar there's
a course that I've made with data camp
that has about four hours worth of
content on deep liar there's some video
lessons it's live coding environment and
mostly it has lots and lots of practice
so this is a good place to go if you
want practice it does cost I think 95
dollars or so so it's not free i if you
will learn more about our deep liar also
some visualization things and reshape -
I've made a video with the Riley that
covers that sort of stuff it's an
introduction the day signs with our you
can find that at the link here again
that's also a product it's not free and
if you wanna learn more about data
wrangling I'm making a second video with
O'Reilly we're gonna film next week that
covers the topics we went to here but
much more in depth with some theory and
some best practices and that sort of
stuff we're filling it next week so look
for that to come out and probably a
month or two and then again here's a
link to the slides thank you for paying
attention to this long what I'll do is
I'll try to answer some questions and
then I'll return through the webinar
over to Roger at the variants Roger why
don't you you can you can scroll through
but I've curated some of the questions
sort of grouped them and maybe one that
you could start with is since people are
doing data wrangling in lots of
different ways right now there's there
one of the themes was the differences
between using deep liar and say sequel
some of the some of the many of the
things people observed could be done in
SQL ok yeah almost all these all of
these things and more can be done with
SQL SQL it is a language that folks is
very heavily on sort data wrangling
stuff
when you're using both our and SQL it's
you face the problem that the languages
are very similar but not identical so
how you do things in our and how you do
mess QL are actually pretty similar but
you have to keep track of what you're
using when and in practice I'm told that
it's just a real pain in the butt so
part of the thing that deep heart did is
it makes an interface for databases
where you could just stick with the are
side of things you can use these
commands I showed you here today and it
will back translate them into the SQL
for whatever data database setup you use
send the query to your database all the
results that happens are for you and you
never have to worry about transitioning
back and forth if you wanted to stick
with SQL and your that's your strong
suit by all means do so I I'm not able
to go into all the stuff to require does
with data frames databases I should say
but if you look up browse vignettes for
deep liar this is our tank I'll show you
all the Vanessa we're in for the deep
layer package that I learned clear a
development version there is a vignette
in deep layers strictly about finca
pieces if you pull that off to contain a
lot more there if all those folks just
google databases and deep higher
vignette and they'll come off at the top
Louis ok thanks and another sort of
theme was because people are using
different packages today and are using
some similar functions or what may seem
like similar functions there were some
there was a theme along that line one
one for example was you know what's how
should I think about gatherers and
spread verses cast and melt what the two
functions do is I mean the end result
for those is almost identical and if you
looked at the code for reshape and
anti-d are besides some optimizations
you see it's almost the same code and
it's the same author for those packages
the neat thing about gathering spread is
their syntax is almost identical whereas
if you look at cast and melt or whatever
reason on the first pass they use very
different syntax which makes a learning
curve a lot harder so I find that
switching or retire it doesn't take very
long to pick up and once you pick it up
it's much easy to remember how to use
each of the functions it should ensure
people think that deeply our obsolete
player or what's your take on that
that's a good question if you can do
what you're doing with deep liar like if
you're working with just data frames and
plyer deep liar is so much faster it
would be quicker to learn do you pyre
and rerun your analysis then to wait for
the analysis definition fire I mean deep
lie is easy to learn and it's very
optimized that said our deep hire really
focuses on data frames that's what's
called deep liar whereas prior worked
with all sorts of structures lists
matrices arrays so if you're using those
aspects applier they're still in play
deep liar can't replace them it doesn't
doesn't do anything that they do there
but if you're working with data frames
or data tables or databases I'd move to
deep liar it's been optimized because
have they assumed that if you're using
deep I are using a data frame if that
makes sense yeah it's oh yeah and I see
even more questions coming in Garrett so
we're not to be able to get to all of
them we're gonna come up on the are your
shortly here's one more though which
probably appeals to people and that is
speed of functions at scale with the
data frame size can you comment on any
experience we've gotten with with
scaling and these functions it's very
positive it's very fast I don't have
numbers often but uh you know you can
you work with millions of rows and not
really be waiting for your data to come
back to you that's why when I say like
if you're using data frames learn deep
liar and run it versus waiting out PI or
PI or could be slow but d-plex nothing
like that it's very fast